un vidéomaton est une émission faite par
vous et qui s'adresse à vous soyez
attentifs vous allez voir des petites
annonces et des messages personnels
si l'un d'eux vous intéresse noter son
numéro
ecrivez-le ou en rappelant ce numéro
nous servirons de boîtes à lettres nous
transmettrons votre courrier à la
personne concernée je m'appelle roland
j'ai 25 ans je suis dessinateur et si je
passe ici parce que c'est parce que je
cherche une femme va bien survenir à
kinguelé en riant - lens parce que comme
tous les gens rigolent en rire en lisant
les annonces de rencontre enfin si je
passe ici si c'est parce que je suis
très timide est vrai je fais un effort
considérable en montrant comme ça si je
me montre c'est parce que je ne trouve
pas trop moche je suis peut-être idiot
de passer à la télé comme ça pour ça
mais enfin
je cherche une femme c'est tout une
femme a aimé pour en fonder un foyer ou
une famille c'est
c'est simple comme tout mais je n'y
arrive pas alors alors je lance cet
appel à la télé écrivez moi aussi il
vous aussi vous cherchez l'amour
écrivez moi bon alors inondé de lyon et
on veut passer un message à ceux qui qui
ont leurs petits problèmes de voiture
qui ont deux trois bagnols et est une
grande maison vient pas de l'été d'or
par exemple qui se trouve à lyon et qui
ont la piscine dans la maison bon nom en
a marre on cherche au moins un travail
un petit travail ça ne suffirait et un
petit tuyau ça ne suffirait est bon
comme on veut pas nous aider on vient
ici pour comment il ya des personnes qui
nous entendent et bon là on cherche
depuis quand même trois ans depuis qu'on
a écouté écoles et en en informant
ras-le-bol alors si on ya quelqu'un qui
nous écoutent bomba qui nous est il nous
écrive fabien amar est dans la merde on
n'est pas des merdes ont fait s'en
sortir et on n'a aucune chance c'est
dégueulasse à penser un petit peu à nous
je trouvais cette chienne de 2 février
1982 avenue rockefeller à lyon je ne
pense pas qu'elles étaient abandonnés
volontairement peut-être n'at-on pas
recherché comme il faut 6 6 et met la
reconnaisse et veulent avoir de ses
nouvelles qu'il me contacte
merci alors je retire l'arrière je
dégage je dégage le frontal je tire je
tire complètement arrière jérôme assez
frontal
la nuque en tire on tire on tire tire en
arrière le poids il n'y est plus si vous
avez mal à la tête
on écrivait écrivez moi ou n'importe
quelle douleur car je suis magnétiseur
évadés saisisse enfin hugo logiques et
plausibles mais qui pèche que durant
final les insurgés qui mènent un bruit
du minatd ce qu'il il a pris mon rythme
h quatre jeunes filles si le canal j
tiji google qui fâchent catherine batty
chetrit eh bien nous sommes un jeune
groupe marocain
nous faisons du fait que du rap en arabe
et si éventuellement quelqu'un est
intéressé pour que lens produisent avec
lui ça ne serait fort utile
bonjour d'abord je souhaite la bienvenue
à tous les tous les lyonnais et
lyonnaises qui commence sont restés à
lyon pendant ce mois d'été est alors
voilà je voulais passer une annonce je
voudrais trouver un homme qui soit
garanti non puissante parce que je
prends la pilule depuis deux ans et ça
m'a beaucoup fait grossir et je vous
montre la photo d'une amie et elle se
fait cinq ans qu'elle l'a promis vous
voyez ce qui lui est arrivé donc c'est
vraiment terrible
alors je recherche un jeu blanc entre 20
et 27 ans
autrement je voulais vendre une moto
c'est la route aux dames à une 500 xt
yamaha et voilà bonjour on se présente
valérie ai dit voilà on sent bien un
petit peu à lyon le soir parce que c'est
un peu paumé il sa bouge pas trop et on
a eu une idée on voudrait organiser une
grande soirée romaine avec tout ce que
cela comporte c'est à dire voilà un
petit exemple
bon si jamais ça vous dit vous pouvez
toujours nous écrire et en france hors
de vous inviter les accords et c'est à
la rentrée alors en ce moment on fait ça
la rentrée on est un grand grenier avec
un très très grande pelouse en bas et
serait ce que d'être très très
sympathique il fait encore beau chaud
donc les tenues l'idéal ça sera bon jour
qui veut s'offrir un futur énarques
je suis étudiant à sciences po je
cherche un job pour l'été prochain c'est
à dire pour jouer à 85
parce que mes études se termine au mois
de juin et le concours de l'ena c'est au
mois de septembre
donc j'ai besoin de le travailler le
préparer mais j'ai aussi besoin d'un peu
d'argent alors c'est pour ça que je
cherche un job à mi-temps dans un
cabinet juridique ou autre j'ai déjà pas
mal d'expérience parce que tous les ans
je fais des jobs un peu à droite et à
gauche et g j'ai également une maîtrise
de droit
j'ai donc de deux je pense de très
bonnes capacités dans le domaine
juridique
je suis débrouillards dynamique et
peut-être aurez-vous la chance donc
d'être le futur employeur d'un enfin
disons le premier employeur d'un futur
député aoun a fait dire une politique
la flûte est un instrument merveilleux
quand on en joue
on ressent à travers les vibrations de
la sonorité quelque chose dit exprimable
je suis étudiant à l'école normale de
musique de paris
et pour ceux qui voudraient profiter de
cet instrument est à la fois pratique de
par sa petite taille qu'on peut
transporter facilement et qui est
tellement grisant je propose de donner
des courants écrivez-moi cognitive anne
hathaway girondine dsk non je ne suis
pas japonaise je m'appelle isabelle j'ai
20 ans je suis étudiante en langues
étrangères à la faculté de paris iii
plus communément appelée censier
j'étudie l'anglais en profondeur
l'allemand l'espagnol de manière un peu
plus légère j'aime également la musique
j'ai fait du piano depuis l'âge de 8 ans
je donne des cours j'aimerais à 20 ans m
l'idée qui me hante depuis ma plus
tendre enfance travailler dans
l'immédiat ceci est quelque chose que
j'ai dans le sang je sens que je suis
fait pour ce métier
nous verrons bien j'aimerais anime une
émission politique qui s'appellerait
mise au point et qui remaniera en
quelque sorte les énormités et les
erreurs prononcé au cours de la semaine
qui aurait précédé le week end par les
hommes politiques les différences
politiques absolument de tous les partis
voilà j'espère que mon message sera
entendu
je vous dis au revoir sayonara japonais
c'est un aspirateur bator brothers ça
pèse 250 g quand vous en avez besoin
vous sortez du placard du tiroir de la
boîte à gants de la voiture sans apporte
quelle surface à n'importe quel moment
de la journée
quand on en a besoin on le saurait on
s'en sert alors ça messieurs dames c'est
pour vous faire voir que j'ai du mal ou
pas ce que vous voyez j'ai dû babouche
parle facilement et ça encore plus
facilement devant les gens plutôt que
devant un écran de télévision
messieurs dames si vous êtes inventeur
si vous êtes fabricant si vous avez un
produit nouveau et bien je me mets à
votre disposition car j'ai l'intention
de changer son ce petit aspirateur
depuis cinq ans ça devient un petit peu
long j'adore la nouveauté
je veux donc changé je me mets à votre
disposition je peux vendre
or de quoi je vous rappelle à n'importe
quel moment de la journée dans n'importe
quel endroit
ça peut être foire-exposition ça peut
être les marchés ça peut être en magasin
je peux même me mettre à la sauver quand
j'ai envie de faire quelque chose croyez
moi je le fais écrivez moi
croyez moi vous regretterez pas du bug
où j'en ai et je le mets à votre
disposition au revoir salut à tous ça
nous sommes des filles du lycée voilà à
puteaux on va faire la pub pour une
nouvelle radio qui vient d'émettre
actuellement à suresnes
c'est un feu de camp soit 194 6
mégahertz
c'est un copain ne dénote pas eu qui
s'appelle charles ix ont faim on le
connaît sous le nom de charlie à
l'antenne sinon ils s'appellent de noix
ouais il est super et puis enfin au lieu
d'écouter les autres radios qui
craignent un peu enfin fréquence 3 c'est
assez sympa il passe à peu tout nu eve
funky enfin tout ce que vous aimez tout
en musique que vous aimez tout ça sympa
ouais et puis on passe ans et on passe
aussi en direct à l'antenne c'est
vraiment génial parce qu'il souhaite un
maximum de notre gueule monsieur la voix
lasse pas on s'éclate
ce ski est un message au conducteur de
la 205 verte qui se trouvait au coin de
la rue du souffle et de la rue réaumur
le 17 décembre vers 15h30 quand il ya
des encombrements et qu'une voiture
s'engage alors qu'elle ne peut pas
traverser le carrefour bloquant ainsi la
rue perpendiculaire et que la personne
ait dans cette voiture persiste à rester
à cette position
ça crée un embouteillage qui d'une
voiture qui ne peut pas passer peut
s'attendre à tout un quartier
alors je sais juste un message à cette
voiture monsieur vous êtes un gros con
que je vous emmerde
bonjour je m'appelle d'ailleurs bonjour
c'est à dire antibes et à l'attack
dooley car je suis à terrier du tibet
venu directement du tibet en france dire
bonjour à la france à ce trop tôt j'ai
d'ailleurs un nombre des diplômes qui
fait que j'ai battu le record tenu par
l'angleterre depuis 1930 au point de vue
diplo mais surtout j'ai un grand amour
pour les enfants même si au tibet je
gardais les temples en mordant le talon
d'achille de ce qu'ils voulaient venir
prendre les trésors
j'ai beaucoup changé la vie de mon papa
puisque je l'a envoyé à maisons alfort
et faire une thèse sur les chiens du
tibet si vous voulez savoir plus sur les
terrier du tibet vous contacter antenne
de jul et bonjour bonjour je m'appelle
coccinelle volkswagen
j'ai 13 ans j'ai eu un moteur en très
bon état
j'ai une carcasse bleu malte métallisé
j'ai beaucoup de gadgets sur ma personne
mais malheureusement il m'est arrivé un
accident tomates sur deux châssis alors
j'ai besoin de quelqu'un pour me soigner
je veux seulement 2500 francs c'est pas
cher bonjour je suis une folle à
l'hélice je m'appelle isabelle j'ai 19
ans je d'étape poster dans l'achat des
photos des affiches ja peu près 60 33
tours est pas du tout quand la tour
je vais tout donner bonjour je m'appelle
andré j'ai 50 ans je suis célibataire je
ne travaille pas depuis trois ans
ceux-ci hélas dû à une opération très
grave
j'ai cependant des revenus j'ai un
problème seul problème c'est l'attitude
bien entendu le fait de ne pas
travailler
aussi j'aimerais rencontrer une fable
entre 30 et 40 ans libérée
n'ayant pas de trop de problèmes
exerçant une profession de préférence
afin de pouvoir faire un bout de chemin
ensemble et de mettre un peu de soleil
sur la route qui nous reste à faire
bonjour je m'appelle jean sarda klein et
je suis le premier recordwoman du monde
de descente libre en patins à roulettes
j'ai descendu une tente de 24% à la
vitesse de 73,5 70 km heure chrono
alors mes patins à roulettes je dors je
mange avec jeu saw des escaliers de
douze à quatorze marches en béton pur et
dur
je m'accroche voiture je fais des
carrioles les des figures artistiques et
j'ai même fait l'amour avec nos patins à
roulettes et j'aimerais beaucoup
travailler dans le spectacle la
publicité ou le cinéma
au fait si une patineuse à roulettes est
d'accord je l'emmènerais bien dans les
descentes pour lui montrer comment on
fait l'amour en patins à roulettes
oui je suis là regardez moi bien je suis
un bon comédien
vous ne connaissez pas ça fait longtemps
justien en france vous connaissez ce qui
est en toi est de vous simplement c'est
que vous connaissez blé mais moi je suis
pas connu mais je voudrais bien
connaître tout le monde et tout le monde
me connaît
j'aimerais bien travailler avec claude
zidi georges leclercq engin est robert
hossein michel blanc oui j'ai déjà
travaillé au liban je suis un bon
comédien je travaillais à la division ce
travail a vaincu son chien l'égyptien
georges championne le libanais mounir la
boudeuse monsieur sidya c'est
d'ingrandes mettre en scène libanais
j'ai travaillé avec eux là bas et ça
fait longtemps je suis en france et par
sont méconnus j'ai cherché j'ai essayé
parce que je suis un libanais j'ai un
petit accent peut-être sur ma langue
française c'est pour ça mais non je
voudrais travailler avec vous bien je
veux me poser à vous
surtout à ce que j'ai prononcé leur nom
ici sinon l'avenir ça souviendra
l'avenir j'ai un fils il a désormais
maintenant si j'arrive pas faire de
cinéma en france
mais monfils il fera mon fils je veux le
dresse ses yeux lui je vais le mettre
sur la route de cinéma je lui apprends
tout le cinéma il est né avec moi c'est
ma passion
lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala
lalala suis en pleine forme
pas vous pas vraiment je vais vous
livrer mon secret tout d'abord je vais
commencer ma petite histoire par il
était une fois deux danseurs
chorégraphes et ils vous enseigne
également la danse
il était une fois à jacky perron
descendant du célèbre conteur charles
perrault et moi sylvia et bien oui on va
vous enseignez ci est bien le rock et le
rock acrobatique ou pour les
nostalgiques pourrais-je parler
peut-être de be bop ou be bop
acrobatique
vous n'êtes pas très enfants croyez moi
à la fin du cours vous allez ressortir
en pleine forme et en plus de ça vous
apprendrez à danser très rapidement et
dans une ambiance très sympathique mais
si vous préférez ou peut vous apprendre
le charleston la valse le tango le cha
cha toutes celles en cela en plus de ça
c'est pas cher on a choisi deux centres
culturels exprès parce qu'on pratique
des tarifs très bas entre 25 et 18
francs au cours d'une heure n'oubliez
pas aussi ça se danse à deux alors venez
en couple au revoir mais qu'est ce que
vous faites là ça vous épate 1 et bien
écoutez je suis venu faire un petit
numéro division où il ya une pièce de 5
francs invisible jeu-là ménage fait 1 2
3 et crac boum ça c'est bien
non mais non nous on cherche du boulot
voyez-vous avant moi j'étais dresseur de
puces et lui il restait des éléphants
car avec l'âge la vue baisse mais il est
il a le bon jour je me propose comme
homme sandwich et ma voiture comme
voiture sandwich pendant quelques mois
pour le compte de toute société pour
tous publicité qu'il intéressera
en les chances évidemment de l'achat
vert synthétiseur yama dixneuf ou à la
rigueur vx7 voilà je travaille dans une
société qui est filiale à 100% la groupe
nationalisé et je viens je m'adresse au
ministre des droits de la femme à la
mi-mai troudi pour qu'elle puisse
examiner mon cas en matière de
discrimination de salaire je suis agent
commercial je visite ses clients
régulièrement et j'ai une différence de
salaire avec mes collègues masculins qui
avoisine des 1800 francs par mois
je n'ai déjà adressé un dossier les
enterre ministre hâtive font que ce
dossier n'est pas encore tout à fait
peut-être au point j'espère qu'elle me
qu'elle prendra ma demande en
considération et qu'elle pourra faire
quelque chose pour moi et pour toutes
les femmes qui sont dans mon cas et qui
cherche à faire aboutir cette nouvelle
loi du 13 juillet 1983 et qu'elles
pourront enfin avoir droit au salaire
qu'elle mérite et auxquelles elles ont
droit cigalon ces cigales dans les
grands vins l'un chante toujours par 15
en douce couleur comme une rose de
fleurs au loin je bave
je vous laisse mon coeur
radieux
venise provençale du ml de nissan alors
voilà je recherche une amie qui se nomme
pierre bonanni et dont nous avions
chanté en anglais le vingtaine d'années
nous faisions du duo cauxcorico
cauxcorico c'est moi le code je cherche
une jolie poule mais je la trouve pas je
cherche de chair je ne la trouve pas et
je suis le coq je viens de naître je
suis tout neuf je suis né le 6 juin
mais mille 1984 et voilà je crois que je
vais trouver une boule
alors je me nomme cocorico je viens donc
j'arrive au monde et j'espère faire une
longue route ce coq maintenant et de
notre réalisation
mon épouse et moi-même qui l'avons
dessinée et que le diffusons en 1955 je
vais environ 12 13 ans je n'ai pas plus
d'offrir le train électrique que je
recherche actuellement à à savoir alors
c'est un train chef d'aïe au la flèche
d'or
alors je ne recherche soit au détail
soit loconte en der un ou deux wagons
pullman et le transfo et les rails alors
voilà la personne qui pourrait
la personne qui pourrait se mettre en
rapport avec antenne 2 et qui possèdent
ce train j'en serais ravi parce que
maintenant je peux me le frire oui il ya
du soleil aujourd'hui dans la rue
partout je pourrais être joyeux comme
beaucoup de gens mais
je suis triste parce que
j'ai perdu mon emploi il y avait du
gazon il y avait des petits oiseaux du
ciel était bleu
autrement dit je viens de vivre une
déception effective
j'ai envie de rencontrer quelqu'un mais
quelqu'un
c'est pour être n'importe qui
ce pote n'importe qui mais à condition
que ça souhait sincère que ce soit vrai
et puis je suis pas marginal mais je
vais d'une manière différente de la
majorité des gens je fais partie de
cette catégorie de 3% et bien que le jeu
pas combien je suis artiste peintre et
j'ai envie donc de rencontrer quelqu'un
qui m'accepte
je suis pour
non moreau prénom emmanuel objet de
plaintes vol circonstances de la plainte
je descendais y asseoir l'avenue marceau
lorsque vers 20h30 une banque de vieux
mas sauvagement agressé pour me voler
tout l'amour que j'avais dans les yeux
alors si vous avez des éléments
concernant cette affaire
écrivez moi tout ceci pour vous dire que
je fais des messages pour d'épandeurs
téléphonique
et voilà un des messages que je fais
mais je peux en faire plein d'autres
pour vous écrivez moi merci bonjour je
m'appelle jean pierre alors je suis à la
recherche de jeunes femmes demoiselle ou
dame peu importe de 22,2 40 ans à peu
près sentimental libéré parce que moi je
suis aussi et voilà je voudrais aussi
bien des parisiennes enfin qui habite
paris qui parlent la langue mais elles
peuvent être scandinave britanniques
belges suisses allemandes et c'est
américaine ou japonaise du moment
qu'elle parle mal an qu'elle soit bien
proportionné qu'elle soit enfin moi je
suis pas en mangeant vous voyez je suis
normal moyens et qu'on s'amuse bien
ensemble pour un mois pour trois mois
pour un an
le secrétaire milliardaire pdg smicarde
enfin d'une mots qu'elle soit agréable
rieuse aimant les défis les mannequins
les toutous les animaux détestant qu'on
fasse du mal aux animaux aux enfants etc
grosso modo ça mais c'est plus pour bien
s'amuser des rapports sexuels bien sûr
agréable imaginatif sous la touche entre
nokia et cetera moisn mesdames je vous
embrasse
et bien voilà j'avoue que j'y croyais
pas beaucoup je suis passé par hasard
j'ai vu le car le vidéomaton je suis
rentré il y avait quelqu'un que je
cherchais depuis 35 ans très exactement
et j'ai fait ça sans aucune espèce
d'espoir et puis ça a marché j'ai reçu
d'abord une lettre de quelqu'un qui me
dit à sa sympathie c'est très aimable
mais c'est pas eu tout ce que cherchait
et la personne que je voulais voir et
bien je les trouvais alors ça c'est
formidable et je dois un énorme merci à
vidéomaton à antenne 2 et cetera et
cetera et cetera
parce que j'ai réussi
bhl est une recherche et qui durait
depuis dix ans et cette personne que
j'avais perdu depuis 35 ans j'en suis
ravi
alors si ça a marché pour moi et c'est
pas de la publicité
je crois que ça peut marcher vos l'autre
voilà
[Musique]